Congress is taking action to prevent a
threatened partial government shutdown
tomorrow the house plans to vote today
on a spending bill to pay the bills
until February 8th the Senate approved
the measure late last night without
adding the money that President Trump
demanded for border security Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy it
sounds like they're playing a game of
kick the can again so here's a question
well the president still signed that
legislation if it reaches his desk
Republican lawmakers hope so in fact
they say they think the president is
going to sign this bill before tomorrow
night's deadline even though it doesn't
contain the wall funding that he had
been asking for it doesn't contain any
additional funding for building the
president's promised border wall just
last week remember he said he would be
proud to shut down the government if he
didn't get five billion dollars to
fulfill his signature campaign promise
but Democrats balked at even 1 billion
dollars in wall funding and Republicans
just can't pass a funding bill without
those Democratic votes so they've come
up with a compromise that is as you
noted Gale a temporary fix it keeps the
government funded but only through
February 8th which gives Republicans a
chance to bargain again for wall funding
in the new year most importantly what
this bill does is prevent a shutdown of
1/4 of the government tomorrow night
which would leave Gale about 400,000
federal employees furloughed right
before Christmas nobody wants that to
happen so what does this mean for the
president's border wall the wall by the
way which during the campaign he kept
saying Mexico was going to pay for it it
turned into a campaign chant right well
now he is looking for ways for the US
government to pay for it that don't
involve funding from Congress he says
he's not giving up in fact he tweeted
one way or the other we will win on the
wall and he has been asking federal
agencies to come up with this additional
money somehow instead and if that
doesn't work some Trump supporters are
taking things into their own hands gale
there is a one Iraq war veteran who
started a GoFundMe page for the wall a
few days ago and he's already raised
more than 2.5 million dollars
all right yeah I heard him say that if
every Trump voter gave $80 it would pay
for the wall we'll see Nancy thank you
very much